im Namen Jesu zur Ehre Gottes des Vaters
diese Worte aus der Bibel stehen wie Sie
hier sehen an der Kuppel vom Berliner
Stadtschloss ja diese Worte diese
christlichen Worte hält die
Kulturbeauftragte Claudia Roth für nicht
weltoffen die christlichen Worte würden
nämlich andere Religionen ausgrenzen
sogar mit argumentiert sie ja und genau
deswegen will sie die Bibelworte mit
anderen Texten überschreiben
gleichzeitig ruft seit ein paar Tagen in
Köln der muizin scheinheilig
nicht weltoffen deshalb unangemessen ein
Bibeltext christliche Worte über den
Dächern Berlins der deutschen Hauptstadt
die Bundesbeauftragte für Kultur Claudia
Roth will jetzt einen Bibeltext
verschwinden lassen an der Kuppel vom
Berliner Stadtschloss sind Zitate aus
der Bibel zu sehen die Grünen
Politikerin findet diese nicht weltoffen
die Bibelzitate wurden von König
Friedrich Wilhelm den vierten ausgewählt
wörtlich heißt es dort dass in dem Namen
Jesu sich beugen sollen aller derer Knie
die im Himmel und auf Erden und unter
der Erde sind immer wieder betonte
Claudia Roth die Bibelworte und das
goldene Kreuz auf der Kuppel
widersprechen der Weltoffenheit die das
Humboldt-Forum auszeichne da will ich
ran in Berlin lässt Claudia Roth also
eine christliche Inschrift auf dem
wiederaufgebauten Stadtschloss verhüllen
und in Köln ruft seit ein paar Tagen der
moecin die Inschrift und demuezin
zweimal Religion im öffentlichen Raum im
deutschen Alltag
scheinheilig findet das
bildchefredakteur Johannes Boje der
Islam wird gefördert das kann man gut
oder schlecht finden das Christentum
wird gleichzeitig zurückgedrängt das ist
scheinheilig und nicht fair weshalb
stößt das der kulturstaatsministerin
nicht auf auch bei dem
antisemitismus-skandal auf der Dokumenta
schaute Claudia Roth Weg jüdische Kultur
wird beschmutzt muslimischer glauben
aber gefördert die Doppelmoral der
ampelregierung Claudia Roth zieht also
gegen Worte zu Felde die seit 2000
Jahren in der Heiligen Schrift stehen
scheinheilig
und darüber sprechen wir jetzt bei uns
im Studio Bild Chefredakteur Johannes
Boje schön dass du hier bist hallo man
hat fast den Eindruck Claudia rothh aber
eventuell diese Worte nicht richtig
verstanden zumindest ist es mehr als
erstaunlich dass sie die als nicht
weltoffen empfindet ja das sehe ich auch
so vor allem aber sind es doch einfach
christlich geprägte Inschriften oder
Bibelzitate in dem Fall die man in
Deutschland ja an X unterschiedlichen
Orten findet die man im ganzen Westen an
ganz vielen unterschiedlichen Orten
findet das liegt einfach daran dass in
früheren Jahrhunderten Staat und Kirche
Start und Religion nicht so eng getrennt
nicht so gut getrennt waren wie das
heute der Fall ist dass es Teil unserer
Geschichte dass es Teil der Bauwerke
hier und wenn man sagt man baut das
Stadtschloss wieder auf als Humboldt
Forum aber doch originalgetreu dann ist
das eben so dann gehört das dazu und da
kann man dann nicht im Nachhinein kommen
und kann sagen also das wollen wir jetzt
aber wiederum nicht und das müssen wir
jetzt überdecken wie multikulturell sind
bei deiner Meinung nach wenn das einige
fördert wird und das andere
zurückgedrängt wird also ich meine bei
während hier Bibeltexte verhüllt werden
sollen darf in Köln jetzt der moecin
rufen was sagt das über unsere
Gesellschaft aus ja ich habe schon den
Eindruck dass das was unsere
Gesellschaft verändert und vielleicht
eine Abkehr von den traditionellen
Werten und der Geschichte auch unsere
Gesellschaft ist sehr gefördert wird in
Deutschland insbesondere unter der
Regierung der Ampel da ganz besonders
bei den Grünen und dass das was
eigentlich für Tradition und Werte
Verbundenheit und die Historie dieses
Landes steht
abgeschafft werden soll und das macht
mich schon sehr nachdenklich denn ich
persönlich finde man kann durchaus
diskutieren welchen Raum der Islam in
unsere Gesellschaft einnehmen soll es
leben in Deutschland ja ganz viele
Muslime und es ist wichtig dass es ihnen
auch gut geht und dass sie ihre Religion
leben können selbstverständlich die
Frage ist nur wie verhalten sich die
Religion zueinander gibt es da eine
Gerechtigkeit und da habe ich im Moment
das Gefühl dass das in die falsche
Richtung geht ganz viele Menschen
empfinden es so können nicht
nachvollziehen warum wenn du jetzt so
weit geht das Stadtschloss es gab so
viele Diskussionen im Vorfeld um
überhaupt diesen Bau jetzt hält man sich
da ganz genau auch an die Geschichte
warum man so weit geht jetzt da zum
Beispiel das ist der Plan ja eine
Kunstinstallation rein zu machen ja
genau nein das ist tatsächlich
unverständlich und gerade wenn man es
ihr habt ja den muezinruf in Köln
angesprochen gerade wenn man das hier
nebeneinander sieht muss man ja sagen es
geht um Religion im öffentlichen Raum
klar der muss ihn ruft eigentlich in der
Moschee aber der Ruf ist ja weit über
die Moschee hinauszuhören also im
öffentlichen Raum wo ist der kulare
atheistische aber auch christliche
Muslime Juden alle nebeneinander leben
und existieren wie gehen wir damit
Religion um und da ist es einfach
überhaupt nicht verständlich und ich
denke auch Grund falsch zu sagen die
christlichen Zitate verbannen wir aber
die muslimischen
Zitate oder rufe in dem Fall die
befeuern wir und den geben wir Raum das
ist eine Ungleichbehandlung das ist
unfair und das führt dann in der
Gesellschaft auch zu Spaltung und zu
auseinander weil natürlich dann viele
Menschen sagen Mensch was ist mit meiner
Geschichte ich bin christlich oder ich
bin atheistisch aber erkenne die
christliche Prägung dieses Landes an
warum wird das abgeschafft werden dass
andere gefördert wird und das heißt also
die Politik die Claudia Roth hier
betreibt ist aus meiner Sicht ganz klar
eine spaltende bedauerlicherweise wie
sollte jetzt auf diese Politik von
Claudia Roth reagiert werden ich glaube
und und hoffe dass sehr dass die Debatte
nicht beendet ist und das jetzt auch
wirklich ein ein
Gegenmaßnahmen kommen und dass ich
prominente Leute äußern und sagen
momentchen mal so geht das eben nicht ja
und besonders perfide finde ich eben
auch dieses einfliegen über eine
Kunstaktion ein temporäres verdecken das
klingt erstmal alles so harmlos ne das
geht ja nicht um viel Mensch da ist
jetzt mal eine Weile was drüber und das
aber die Wahrheit ist ja das Claudia
Roth schon immer ein Problem mit dieser
Inschrift hat und dass er wohl eben der
Gedanke dahinter steckt dass christliche
Zitat aus dem öffentlichen Raum zu
verbannen und wenn man das macht dann
muss das eben für alle Religionen gelten
Salat das würde glaube ich unsere
Gesellschaft nicht gerecht werden denn
Religion ist immer mit der Gesellschaft
verbunden und sollte es für die
Gläubigen auch sein dürfen ist es meine
Meinung insofern hoffe ich dass die
kulturstaatsministerin hier doch noch
mal ihre Handlung überdenkt aber ich
muss euch ehrlicherweise auch sagen so
richtig viel Hoffnung habe ich nicht
weil was ich bislang von Claudia Roth in
ihrem Amt wahrgenommen habe Stichwort
Dokumenta das war alles andere als
überzeugend ganz klare Worte von
Johannes Boje Bild-Chefredakteur vielen
herzlichen Dank für Deinen Besuch hier
im Studio danke euch und im Studio ist
jetzt bz-kolonist Schub Helios schön
dass Sie hier sind diese Worte hat
Claudia Roth die vielleicht nicht
richtig verstanden was genau spricht aus
diesen Worten gegen Weltoffenheit um
diese Worte gibt es schon einen langen
Streit es gibt da hole ich mal ganz kurz
aus es gibt auf der Dachterrasse des
Schlosses in Berlin bereits eine Tafel
auf der Tafel distanziert sich die
Bundesregierung also die Bundesstiftung
ist es ja die hinter dem Schloss steht
aber der Bundesregierung gehört
distanziert sich die Bundesregierung
bereits in schriftlicher Form
eingraviert in eine Tafel von diesem
Spruch der da an der Kuppel eingraviert
ist und jetzt kommt der nächste Schritt
das reicht ihnen nicht Claudia Roth hat
als Beauftragte des Bundes für Kultur da
die Hoheit und sie sagt und ihre Leute
sagen und die Stiftung sagt das reicht
nicht wir wollen auch diese Worte
unkenntlich machen und jetzt kommt der
Punkt sie sagen diese Worte bedeuten
dass sich alle dem Christentum
unterwerfen sollten das ist ein
Missverständnis diese Worte kommen von
langer her die sind 2000 Jahre alt da
hat Paulus zu den Urchristen gesagt
kniet nicht vor dem römischen Kaiser
sondern nur vor Gott das heißt also das
ist ein rein frommer Ausspruch der hier
formuliert wird
wie multikulturell sind wir überhaupt
noch wenn das einige fördert wird und
das andere quasi also gerade
zurückgedrängt wird also ich meine
hier werden Bibeltexte wahrscheinlich
verhüllt und währenddessen darf in Köln
der moicin rufen also was sagt das über
unsere Gesellschaft noch rausziehen
rufen darf ist eine Entscheidung aus
Köln also das heißt ja der Muezin dafür
überall rufen nur jetzt eben neuerdings
auch nach draußen über Lautsprecher
sowie das in arabischen Ländern gang und
gäbe ist das ist eine Entscheidung da da
kann man sich drüber streiten das ist im
Rahmen der Religionsfreiheit
wahrscheinlich auf jeden Fall richtig
nur fragen wir uns natürlich wenn
zeitgleich nicht von denselben Personen
aber doch von der Politik aus dann
sozusagen christliche Symbole
zurückgedrängt werden dann passt hier
etwas nicht mehr zusammen das nimmt man
ganz deutlich wahr und das nehmen unsere
Leser und Zuschauer auch sehr deutlich
war dass sie sagen das kann doch jetzt
nicht wahr sein es geht übrigens bei dem
Schloss in Berlin nicht nur um die
Inschrift sondern auch um das Kreuz oben
drauf auch das Kreuz wird bekämpft kurz
kurz gesagt warum ist da ein Kreuz weil
in der Gruppe eben sich mal eine Kapelle
befand deswegen ist das so das war also
mal ein christlicher Ort
immer ganz klar historische Gründe beim
Stadtschloss wie geht es da jetzt weiter
was soll da überhaupt hingepinselt
werden wie ist der Plan und wie ist vor
allem die Reaktion aus der Politik auf
diesem Land also die Bundesstiftung und
darüber die beauftragte Claudia Roth die
sagen wir suchen jetzt nach einer
Kunstinstallation wie wir dann diesen
Spruch über Blenden können also sie
suchen gerade auch nach technischen
Möglichkeiten nach Projektoren und dann
wollen sie sozusagen da gibt es auch
schon Vorschläge von Künstlern die
eingeholt wurden dann wollen sie den
Bibelspruch überlagern mit eben anderen
Zitaten aus anderen Schriften um
deutlich zu machen dass sie eben
weltoffen sind und für alle Religionen
da aber noch einmal dieser Spruch
schließt keine Religionen aus das ist
einfach eine Art christliches
Glaubensbekenntnis dass man sich Gott
verpflichtet fühlt und keiner weltlichen
Macht
vielen herzlichen Dank für diese
Einschätzungen zu diesem Thema sie
werden auch ganz genau beobachten wie
diese Entscheidung dann gefallen wird
wie es dann da weitergeht und was jetzt
dann bald auf dem Berliner Stadtschloss
auf der Kuppel dann dort beim Humboldt
von stehen soll das werden wir
beobachten schauen wir uns ganz genau an
danke für Ihren Besuch
[Musik]